and please be patient as we set up our
live streaming for today
let's start a quick question do we have
90 minutes today our system in australia
um
we're scheduled for 60 minutes but as
you and i discussed we can certainly go
over that
depending on the number of questions
available
don't feel rushed
thank you
and again to our
attendees
stand by for one moment
all right
thank you for your patience uh
welcome to our career master class
emerging careers in data science ai and
machine learning
and our
speaker today is amol mahamuni uh
program director of multi-cloud
management platform at kindrel
development lab a new spin-off from ibm
and just before we get started uh
controls
uh please enter your
questions for amal in the q and a box
and we will keep track of them there
and we'll be asking those toward the end
in the q a part of the
session
uh in chat if you address it to all
panelists we'll be able to see it
you do have the option of chatting
amongst yourselves
but if you want a muller and i to see
this
please use all panelists and
we'll also be doing a couple of polls
once at the beginning once toward the
end
and what i'd like to do now is
present the first one
it's pretty simple
we'd like to get a feel for
how much experience members of the
audience have
so if you don't through that and if
you're in the streaming service and
don't see the poll widget
you can put your answer in the comments
um
we also ask how you're feeling today
because since the pandemic began
we find that
it affects people's moods so i'm going
to check in with you and
see how you're doing
and we have about 15 seconds left
so please get your answers in
okay and
i will share the results with you
so we have an interesting uh
bimodal distribution we have a number of
people who are students at university
um
and then
but the biggest
group the plurality is
people with 10 years of experience so we
our audience covers a broad range today
i'm also
now that you were
curious about that and let me
go ahead and introduce you
so
i'm all is the program director for
kindred development lab on their
multi-cloud management platform um over
35 years of product development and
research and software
so a lot of experience and expertise to
bring to you
it's a holder of seven u.s patents
and a number of international
publications
a recognized expert in the industry and
he studied at nit case
throth call and also
university of washington so
with that
i would like to
welcome a mall
thanks to thank thanks for the intro
and it's uh
you can activate your camera now
oh sure let me do that
yeah am i audible
yep
okay terrific so thanks to it
uh just a quick um in the intro just to
correct that i'm grad from iit varanasi
i used to be itv issue as it was called
earlier and mba from cornell
so a little bit
that's perfectly all right so look
forward to um there's a pretty elite
audience i can see nearly half of you
are over 10 years experience so what we
do is that i'm going to confine my
session to just about 40 45 minutes
and we're gonna leave enough time for
the q a right so let's go with that
uh just to set the context i wanted to
see if i can also start shading
my slides
and is this visible
let me take a quick look
yes
okay perfect so let's get started
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
first start off with
what exactly is the aiml there is a lot
of talk the town and then what's the
reality there we'll also talk about what
kind of lies into the near future and
that's what's very important right
because a lot of speculations about it
and maybe there are a lot of myths which
needs to be dispelled right we can
because there is a lot when anything is
talked about so we'll talk about what
the industry expo is saying what does
the gartner and forester and is say
about it and what's an opportunity in
front of us and that's that's very
important right
and as a really close session uh we
should also talk about what does it mean
from the overall job by participants
perspective many of you may have that
question so maybe i'm going to appear in
that question to an extent
so
let's let's just go through a quick
intro
so if i get started with this right and
why is this not working for me
this is what happens okay
so let's start with you know what's
cognitive and if you see on the extreme
top right over here i chose one of these
things which is in stock contrast right
if you see a ship sailing over there
which was called the very first ship
um which was the
the first marine expedition which was
called mayfair in 1600
and that was the first ship which
actually sailed from england to the us
after of course you know the columbus
discovered america's in trying to
actually find out what is the ocean
patterns and how can the trade winds be
right and what you see to the left of it
is an autonomous ship and that is an air
power ship which is driverless
there is no human into that and it is
doing an expedition across the atlantic
in trying to do oceanography studies
right so that's the kind of contrast
that we see today where has reached
right where
in the last maybe just about 30-35 years
very very sharing
so when we talk of cognitive systems one
of the things which comes to mind which
is here at the bottom is my favorite
which is boston robotics
and this is where um you can really see
how we can have a human-like behavior
right you can see a rover actually doing
fighting and this is not one of those
science fiction movies this is one of
the realities just to give a glimpse of
where we believe the ai is actually
ridiculous right which is trying to have
a robo dog or a robocop in reality which
can actually go in a situation
where humans may not even possibly enter
in right which could be the difficult
situation or commando situations right
and when we talk of um
the reasoning and explainability and
interpretability we also kind of touched
about what are the what are the ethics
in ai what is
uh the kind of bias
what is the kind of you know the moral
bound that we really need to go with as
we really talk about the year right
so i want to actually start off with
what's the history as we believe in the
year right so
there is a lot which is being talked
about maybe in just about five to ten
years less than 10 years as much fact
but if you look at the history of it
this was the first time that yeah as a
word an artificial rather natural
intelligence was coined was in 1956
which was in the um that small
conference right which is where the word
was even coined in but even before that
alan turing actually proposed the first
you can call it as artificial
intelligence or something like you know
the machine learning kind of turing test
and in case you don't know turing is the
one who actually broke the first code of
the german enigma machines
in the world war two and that's been a
kind of a computer model that really
followed right and as we go through
how ai has progressed or how
you know entire machine learning has
progressed i will not call it as a deep
learning yet uh you can see that there
was some kind of uh you know slack in
between you can see a kind of you know
the pro there which is nearly 30 years
there was nothing much which happened
but i recall that in my
uh you know when i used to spare work
for india space research i've been about
27 years in ibm and now in general
uh but one of the first things that i
was trying to do for the remote sensing
satellites was to look at what is the
optical camera cloud cover because you
can process the entire image and it's
going to be fear west because there is a
sprinkle cloud over there right the
white cloud the dark clouds and that is
where i started using the hopkins model
for instance and the whole neural
networks for the first time right so
it's been there since about you know the
early 90s and you know pretty prominent
and you can see you know a lot of the
history over there shall not go through
all of it
but one of the things that i want to
call out is if you really look at the
alex net the four cnn network which came
in 2012 of course nearly time that
serials kind of you know brought to the
world right
and then there's a google's
tensorflow libraries and you know many
other things right but why now right
what is different and why we're really
talking today
so when we're really talking today if
you really look at the classification
techniques that you have the clustering
techniques such as
base or stochastic gradient descent or k
n decision tree many of these things
even with uh learnable weights actually
existed
uh for the last 50 60 years right
and as we really go today we are really
talking of the multi-layer perceptrons
mlps visible to the cnn feed forward
methods
and all of these has come into the
existence particularly because now we're
talking of the data which is the new
natural resources people call it which
is at your disposal and this data you
can even get from giggle data set so you
can get it from your enterprises
wherever it is
much more easily at the iops that you
really want to consume
the previous hardware i would say about
to get back and i remember the array
processors that i use in india spaces
which is actually at five megahertz you
don't believe it right i'm not talking
here that's just five megahertz
and we're talking of matrix inversion
and matrix multiplication taking minutes
uh so obviously the access to the data
the access to the hardware which is all
of the gpu tpu npu the neural posting
your nato tends to posting units and all
of it right and the best part of it is
all of these in the cloud and when i say
cloud it is hybrid multi-cloud right you
can get this inventory from any of your
favorite uh which are the cloud
providers that you have it could be
amazon aws or whatever it is right and
that makes it easier lower set of
gravity for you to actually go through
it right so that's something that i want
to call out now when we talk of an
artificial intelligence again there are
multiple terms which kind of you know is
being spoken in a rather synonymous way
which is the dl and ml
so i just want to kind of you know drop
a distinction before you go deeper into
that
is when we talk of ai that's a kind of a
larger concerns and that's a large
boundary that's large and simple
and that could be anything like even a
rule-based system and in a decision tree
based system right but when we talk
about machine learning it is all about
machines
um being thrown at a problem and being
thrown with the data trying to learn by
itself what needs to be done now of
course we can argue it could be
super is learning like um classification
regression or it could be unsupervised
learning and of course as you know
suppose learning is the one which is
little clumsier because you could have a
labor data
getting labeled data from millions of
accounts in your data set and the data
sets are humongous today we talk about
that later
when you talk of a real-time data
toucher you can't really have the
labeling done in real time the streaming
data right
so having a label data to do this kind
of a supposed learning particularly for
a class imbalance problem is nightmare
and that is where something like an
unsupervised learning like clustering
dimensionality reduction like principal
component analysis auto encoders you
know any one of these things can come in
and of course the reinforcement learning
which is more of experience based
learning and here we are really looking
at some kind of a balance between
exploration and exploitation exploration
of the new territories as well as as it
learns the new models right as well as
you know the new techniques to
understand what needs to be inferred and
of course what it learns over the fly
which is more of an exploitation right
so this is you know broader discussion
uh distinction between these but if you
really talk of you know the ml
it could be anything from even a dc
entry in a base you know the nearest
neighborhood k n hd boost any of those
or deals which could be you know v and
itsm i'll give a couple of examples as
we really go
use more of these i would say the rnn
the recurrent neural network models
uh which is more of a deep learning and
the reason we call it deep in a way is
because the number of
uh the perceptrons in the number of
layers that you really have in the
neural nets right which makes it more
complex which makes it more costlier
which but which also makes it more
profound right and more accurate when
you talk about precision and recall and
f1 values is certainly a little better
so this could be again the gr user the
auto encoders are you know my favorite
is lstm the long short memory uh or even
the the hirachial temporal memory that
we use quite often
now let's just look at you know where is
the ai
uh trying to invade into the life right
hand
i would really look at it this way which
is it has invaded into all the parts of
life today and it is going to continue
to do so right
more so more often than what it has done
in the past
so i'll just speak in a few of the
examples over here of course there's a
there's a big list over here
when you talk of an advanced analytics
and argue ticketless iit which is a
nirvana state that we all believe that
we'll probably get into from the
services management perspective
we look at what is the kind of a
predictive modeling uh anything like a
demand forecasting that you do in
you know your retail and you can look at
you know multiple examples for you like
speech implementation motion detection
but let's just look at you know what is
what is real and what could be happening
right
in real life if you're looking at you
know the
if i take simplest of the examples
that the vaccine trial in general the
clinical trial used to take little over
a decade and i'm not talking off long
back to just about just about five to
ten years back i would argue that in any
vaccine like what we you and me all of
us must have taken right which was
launched in less than a year is only
possible because
the clinical trials you can imagine
which is life-saving drug today is being
expedited and that is exactly how the
lives have been saved right on this
mother earth
the same thing which could be from
anything from an augmented reality
augmented reality or virtual reality
which could lead into the remote
operation you're not going to have the
doctors in you know few countries and
few regions which are going to be in
far-flung areas and you can probably
operate it
so many of these things which will
transform our lives for tomorrow
um is what is happening to the ai and
that's the gist of this slide right but
let me also give a couple of examples
which are absolutely real and i am not
making it up right
surprising that it may sound but just
couple of years back i wouldn't reveal
more details for the confidential
reasons but
when germany won the world cup
it was an ai driven algorithm can you
believe that right because there was
this entire data with all the sensors
and actuators which gets collected
through the iot devices
was analyzed to look at what is the best
strategy and you can have multiple
strategies right like an ai code which
is are the short passes better is the
position of ball more important or is
the defenders more important or do we
really have some kind of you know
somebody who is actually attacking that
towards the goal right so that's exactly
the strategy that ai can actually drive
to give a winning formulation right so
that's where we are graduating and here
is an example
ah still
very closely i don't know how many of
you kind of make out what it is right
this is the edmond day bellamy and in
case you know and you haven't heard
about it
this is a painting which is sold just
about two years back at south bay the
christians i think it was the testies it
was a twisties for nearly half a million
dollars
now what's so special about this
painting
is because it's not a human drawn
painting right now why did i keep this
right at the bottom of this painting
this is real right you can google it
right any search engine
so ai drone printing
is actually being sold for half a
million dollars today and that's a
reality right
now what does it mean right that exactly
is a point that is making that the
invasion of ai into all walks of life is
to an extent that in the yesteryears
water that we would have thought about
which is possible only through maybe
human intelligence and human training
which could be anything like um
you know writing a poem or writing a
novel or painting a picture or anything
like that right an art such as this is
actually possible uh through ai right so
it looks scary to an extent but don't
get along we should talk about it right
it is something which can be pain or a
boon depending on you know how you want
to use these tools right obviously
so before we go in the next one i also
want to talk about what are the
challenges in ai right
so when we talk of ai there is this kind
of a notion and i must also warn you
that you know many people come here come
in and believe that you know i've done
this udemy course and i've done this
coursera course and i've done this data
science certification of three months
and i all equipped right i'm all geared
up and i'm ready to jump into the
industry with asking for you know dual
the compensation which i get right guys
that's not real right there is there is
a science behind it and it's about the
data at rest almost speaking to you
it is the data which is giving the
system of engagement or system of
insights
uh to the remedial actions
for you to really derive that actionable
insight and making the data of a
business purpose right making solving a
business problem with that and then
you're talking of humongous data you're
talking of you know what we call as the
four v's of the data right which is the
volume of our data
the velocity or the real-time nature of
the data
the veracity of the data velocity is the
fuzziness of a data right
uh quite often when particularly
non-support is learning we talked about
unlabeled data right
it does not necessarily tell you with
the level of conviction on what you
really want to info
and you still want to infer something
out of it and get a better precision
like 80 percent plus right and get
better reference score but still right
now that's an art and a science together
so it's not just a science it's an art
and science together and any art when it
is learned takes time for you to
actually be an expert in that right so
i don't want you to jump the seat and
say well i did two courses and hence i'm
equipped
and when you talk of ai and we talk of
you know data science in general i just
want to make sure that we all understand
that it comprises of multiple things
right it comprises of
when you actually start accessing the
data and then there's a
data residency norms data handling
rounds data security pronouns data
staging
data amputation wrangling whatever it is
right you'll have some kind of missing
data sets how do you really get those
which is imputation electricity data
massaging and enrichment and many of
these things right i'll just give an
english example right
one of the projects that i had just
about four or five years back was
actually trying to get mapping of the
indian citizens i know there's an
international audience
and you know what
the problems problems are profound my
name can be spelled which is a you know
maharashtrian name can be spelled as a b
muhammadi mohammed b mohammadi mahamuni
b you can look at the variations right
and you still have to decipher that is
the same person now i'll tell you no
more problems than that in data handling
right and the deciphering are inference
that you're gonna drop
i can write my address in five different
ways guys i can say you know i'm in
front of indian public school or i can
say i'm behind binaka motors right now
what is it it's a driving direction but
that's an address right
worse still it can say you know i'm
behind rama temple and under people tree
well now you know
how do you find it so there are lot of
problems in understanding the data right
not just the data amputation security
and residency norms
and of course you know there are many
things that we look at from preparation
of the data which is the data
engineering stage to the data platform
stage to the data science stage to the
analytics to visualization stage right
so it's about the data the modeling and
the visualization and of course any
actions that you take over there right
and when we talk of multiple things we
should i just want to spend a little bit
of time on this white box black box
testing white box as you know is
obviously something which is
more open it can explain you
why the predictions are made
uh why and what is the influence which
is being made right which could be
any deep learning like random forest
kind of a model black box is more for
decentry linear regression any one of
those right but then the white box has
better accuracy black box will be more
expendable when you talk of
explainability it is expandability its
reasoning
its interpretability you know many of
those things right but let's just talk
about you know a few other things which
are subtle in um you know
anything which you really
from an implementation deployment
perspective need to be careful about and
that one when i really talk about
that is this ethics and the moral and
the trust
and the responsibility right it's very
important for us to talk about it right
and i really want to get yeah i really
want to spend a minute or two because
when you really get this tool in hand
right it's a double-edged sound
when you get the biggest two in your
hand which is the data
um the data obviously it could be hipaa
protected could be something which is
you know the data handling norms as i
said right but even beyond that
uh it can introduce an unwanted biased
algorithm by a strike and it actually is
more profound when you have a class
imbalanced problem when you do over
sampling of the data and then you are
looking at a bias which could be a
gender bias which could be an age bias
which could be a color bias and all of
it and we've got to be very careful in
the influences
uh and it could even be a training data
set for you know supposed learning that
you take right biasing is very important
thing actually there are
there are bodies there um
their collaborations first amazon google
microsoft ibm the partner to really look
at what are the ethics of ai
and what they also preach is there are
certain professions for instance maybe a
police
or judge or a nurse or soldier
it may not actually be handed over to ai
right so there are a lot of science
fiction movies but you know don't trust
that it's very unlikely that this
weaponization of the eye is very very
serious thing and it will be given in
their hands right but also look at the
trust and morales of the ai right and
that is the responsibility
which is you are responsible for the
data protection the privacy protection
and even the influences that you trust
be little careful on that i just want to
kind of you know mention that and of
course you know talking about the
explainability uh it's very important
that when you're looking at a medical
profession and there are few problems
honestly which are unsolved so let's
look at autonomous vehicles today right
i don't actually name any particular
company over here but they're at least
about half a dozen company which created
a product which has hit the road today
now what does it really mean right if it
really gets into trash because it reads
something wrong the problems are
are plenty over here right if there is
an autonomous car which is driving and
there is somebody in front of you and
you know that it's inevitable that you
got to actually go and hit the car
because there is somebody who's going to
bang you at the back
you have a choice to swell the car and
go to the right above the left right
into the lane change but there are other
cars over there who do you hit
the question is you are going to hit
somebody probably you will save yourself
but you know
i mean there are these problems which
are extremely complex problems
it has to be solved with the compassion
it has to be solved with the humanity
angle it has to be solved with you know
the way we're really going to put this
technology used right so i just want to
you know put that into your minds that
whenever we really look at this uh even
the explanability reasoning interpret
interpretability there are multiple
models that you can use over here
quite often it is you know the lama
sharp or any surrogate models that we
use
basically particularly in the white box
modeling to look at
why do you arrive at a certain inference
and maybe it is mandated sometimes right
sometimes in medical imaging for
instance
one way you can really look at it which
is for instance right here in bangalow
that is manipur hospital
and ibm had a collaboration over four
years back to look at
millions of x-rays millions is not
possible for any human but to look at
millions of x-rays
to act to find out from any soft phrase
whether a particular lump could be
cancerous
or it could be diagnosis of whatever it
is right from your mrs scanner which is
images that are talking about so that
way we can say it's it's a great thing
that ai is really trying to help you
right but if the diagnosis goes wrong
you can imagine it could even be life
threatening so
uh again explainability reasoning
becomes very important
and the other aspect that i want to
bring up is
what you see over here is
the kind of you know the sequence that
you really follow
uh all the way from sources of the data
i talked about the four v's right the
velocity volume velocity and a variety
of data which could be real time
stimulator extremely difficult to handle
see theoretically you can see many of
these things which looks like you know
beautiful thing when if you're learning
if you're still a student right if
you're into the industry you would have
faced it if you're going to handle four
terabytes of a data coming in every
single day
how do you even transmit it from a
source to where it is going to get
processed one can argue yes i'm going to
use the lambda function and servo is
computing an open whisk and it can be
done at a source these are good and
great right but then really look at
punching through the firewall and the
security and you know all the
guardrails in the landing zone which our
clients have put up over there how do
you really invade you know there is very
difficult
uh but of course there are ways in which
it can be handled and then there is this
historical time series data again data
amputation is a problem over there
particularly for iot domain
uh you don't you don't get the data
which is the continuous streaming data
right and there are limitations to the
implication as well
to the data processing which is data
enrichment cleaning all of those right
and i talked about the enrichment in
that address or the name just
recognizing a name is so difficult and
associating that with a single person
and having five different driving
directions associating that with single
person address
so the feature processing feature
extraction feature selection many of
these things right why do i mention this
is
while it looks pretty earliest for one
to do this you can see probably an
extreme right i know that's visible
but there are about only one fifth of
the organization which can actually put
out the train models
into production
why is it important for us to look at
that means that the four fifth of the
models which are built actually does not
hit the road
right and why is that happening that's
because maybe your accuracy or precision
and recall is not good or the model
needs to be retraining or it does not
have the active learning or continuous
feedback
and you need to probably have a
different data set or different labeling
or whatever it is right there could be
multiple reasons why it does not work
now what we're talking today is the auto
ops mlaps i don't know whether you heard
these terms but there is phenoms and
model ops and githubs and autopsy and
many of these obscene terms that you
will keep hearing right the one which i
actually talking over here is more of an
email ops
where you can get the data which can be
through any pipeline any message bus any
which way you get it you can have your
argo cd go cd any ci cd pipeline which
can actually work on it
and
you have this hyper parameter tuning
choosing a model tuning the model
evaluating a model and even deploying
the model
it's all something which is automated
through this workflow
uh so it is been a boon yet again is
good that you can actually do it of
course none of this happens in real time
uh there is a lot of work which is
happening towards this in the auto ml or
not ops kind of a space with that i want
to quickly switch and i'm going a little
too fast because i'm actually giving
enough time to the q a
uh so i'm going to give a specific use
case over here from the industry that i
belong to which is the industry which is
itsm industrial id services management
industry
and what you see on the right hand side
is the
gartners
i would call it as you know the ai ops
loop which is the monitoring
service desk on engage and the
automation which is act right which is
obviously engage in act and how does it
actually happen in real itsm systems i
will give you just one example of there
which follows the
cross industry standard process which
you all must be familiar
uh which primarily talks about the data
preparation modeling and this is where
we spend a lot of time
the you know the rule of the game i
would i would probably say there are two
rules of the game right
uh what people say is garbage and
garbage out right unless the data speaks
to you unless the data is prepared well
uh which is what the over sampling and
class imbalance and few other things
that we talked about right the model
will be wrongly trained and you'll have
wrong influences right and you will have
a lot of false positives and reduction
of horse positive is not easy in any cnn
rn modeling
and it takes time to settle right all of
this even if you really either you'll
have to trade off between what's an
accuracy and what's the time for it to
settle right it keeps ringing quite
often and it can get overdrive point
after turn i don't know whether you've
seen that but it get outlined quite
often if you take anything like a dt
kind of a model for instance and if you
keep on throwing a lot of data sets at
eight
it may get over trained to the extent
that it actually stops being a machine
learning model
it just tries to choose the best option
as if it's a rule-based model right so
all of these things one has to take care
of into the data stage or data
engineering stage itself but of course
there is a continuous evaluation and not
everybody can even effort to do the
envelopes that i just talked about
earlier
so here is the
gartners view and i think for positive
time i'm just glazing at once right let
me just go to the next one over here
this is where
most of the services industry is
released as well on that right and the
reason services industry is
look at the problem that we have in the
services industry and if i really draw
our attention take a little bit of a
data from services industry to
what we see every day right
we talking of close to about i don't
know seven plus billion people on this
mother earth
and surprising that it may sound but
about five billion mobile phones
and five billion internet users
right
the amount of data which it creates is
expected to be 160 zettabytes
and i know you get the idea of a
zetabyte but it is something like
you have the terabytes and the petabyte
and extra white and zettabyte and yota
white and i can keep going right so
that's the amount of data which is
roughly about 400 extra bytes of a data
per day this humongous data
so what you really learn in the studies
today and most of you i think half of
you are already probably working on this
uh handling this data is absolutely not
easy to that extent that even your
we call it as the infrastructure that
you have did not even allow you to
handle that in real time right yeah
now when switching back to the itsm
problem over here
uh we call it more of a descriptive to
predictive to preventative right and if
i give a very layman example over here
uh you know we used to probably patter
backs when we go to the docks when
somebody probably falls sick not you but
somebody falls sick he goes to the dog
and the doctor describes the medicine
although they observe this and nothing
against doctor medical proportion but
they normally tell you
that you know why don't you try this
antibiotic they don't use the word
private this what is why did you take
this antibiotic broad spectrum and come
back after two days and tell me how it's
working right and then you come back and
say hey it's not working i said okay i'm
going to change it for you right i'll
change the dose for you so there is no
personalization over here right based on
your dna sequence and based on your
historical time analysis of your gene or
your dna
or your genome sequence there is no
personalized medicine yet into the
industry i mean there's a lot of work
which is happening over there so that's
the problem today right
now one can also of course argue from
this you know the health related thing
that you know what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna probably start meditating and
doing yoga or whatever it is
which could be or maybe start running
which is preventive but better still is
to really do proactive actions for you
to be preventative right so which is
exactly how this journey is which is
descriptive to diagnostic to predict you
to prevent it
which is the nirvana state which is a
ticketless id so one cannot take a
pattern back today to say that if there
is a ticket which is raised in ik
industry and ticket is after the
monitoring agent detects a problem it
creates a ticket or problem record right
and then you can say well i'm gonna have
all the automation of the world and i
can actually create a workflow and i can
detect the problem and i can fix the
problem and validate it and deploy it
well good and great right and have
entire cicv continuous integration with
the pipeline but the problem still
remains that the problem has occurred
right and the best ticket is the one
which does not occur
which means it's a ticket exciting can
you actually go to that stage which is
prevented you right which is the entire
time learn act right and then multiple
things we call it three legged stool
which could be a monitoring system which
does any monitoring on any system
are your logs which is the kind of you
know the heartbeat that you really
produce every time right there are logs
which is a lot of information a lot of
volume
difficult to handle but if you have the
logs and the topology which is the
connectivity and the affinity data the
density of magnitude as well
and of course the metric data then that
gives you the three legged stool for you
to work on
to start creating the system of record
to system of engagement or system of
inference
to
what is this you know the ticketless id
or the preventative
so i'm gonna probably give very quick
example and um or maybe just a minute on
this right
this is the real life example what you
see in the app's work range
which is the ai operations workbench you
build right
where the level of automation has the
level of complexity that you see because
the data sources should be applied
and it's not just about the variety of
data variety of data sources not just a
variety of data formats right variety of
data sources
and few of those could be real time
non-real time and there are different
sets of data right the different key
performance indicators there are
different call data records there are
different tickets there are different
monitoring triggers that you get
uh they're different optimization that
you need to do such as densify for
instance uh you get different traces
from dynamics data are new really
science logic what have you right there
various tools out of the market right
and then you do various things on the
data such as observability such as
interpretability
and you know all of the analytics that
you do for you to be able to do
different
visualization different remedial actions
and different actionable insights
now the reason i say remedial action
says again going to the ticketless id
it does not suffice this let me get an
example yet again right if you go to the
dot and say well you know tell me what
has happened to me you can ask a couple
of questions he or she and when you tell
them the symptoms
it's very difficult from coming from a
symptom to the root cause and that is
why ai plays a significant role right we
call it a situation creation
so it's not the just the anomaly
detection of your data set
it's not just about dynamic thresholding
and of course all of these which is
looking at the characteristic of a data
to change your thresholds in the
monitoring for you to reduce the fast
positive random thresholding
but getting to that cognitive root cause
analysis going from a symptom to the
cause is a very difficult thing
and i was just giving example of the
medical science or you know you go to
the docs and the doctors are going to
say okay this is what has probably
happened to you
but then what what is the remedial
action right
so it doesn't stop at that the doctors
cannot tell you well it appears that you
know you got a cold but then what do you
do about it of course you got to take
something right short term long term
tactical strategic right you've got to
play both of those right so that's where
we are really looking at something which
is
an action and actionable insight which
can even be automated which is remedial
actions right and
then obviously the different
visualization you can do it's in
graphene or keyboard or angular yeah t3
what are the technologies right the
various technologies not all of those
are compatible with each other and
that's why we got to actually view the
solution together there are multiple
assets there are
multiple
professions which are actually built
around it so i'll probably
skip most of it but it talks about what
is the kind of a technology train and
what lies ahead
uh anything from augmented reality to
blockchain uh or quantum computing uh we
don't have much time to talk quantum but
that's
something that we are very passionate
about
uh so just to leave this thought in your
minds quantum computing when it becomes
a reality will be about 100 million
times faster than today's traditional
computing now how about that right now
did i say 100 million times or infinite
it doesn't matter if it is a million
times faster that's okay to write
because we're really talking of
something of course that's not a reality
today but in experimental conditions
which is nearly at one degree kelvin
quantum computing does happen where you
talk of qubits and the spin of a qubit
or the kind of you know the straight
transition of the pivot it represents
the way we today look at conventional
computing as binary but all of this is
possible through ai
uh anything like you know the
homomorphic models right which is
without decrypting a data you can
process the data right much deeper
insights over that so many of those
things let's just look at kind of you
know switch the gears and this let's
look at because i'm looking at the cloud
i'm going to leave this shot for a while
now why is this important those of you
are aware of it this is the gartner hype
and you would see this cycle anywhere
why is it important is if you look at
somewhere at the bottom right another
person is visible over here
but i'll probably choose a better server
here which is pointer as a laser right
so this talks about the innovation
trigger where people talk about the
technology and there is a peak of
inflation expectation
there is a lot of talk of a town and
people expect a lot of robocops movies
which come in a lot of media plays and
people think that the world hunger
problem is solved right
well i mean we are really talking 1.5
degree centigrade which is what is
happening at glasgow and we can solve
the problem for the next 50 years as a
different story but we're talking about
peak of
expectation that this technology is
going to solve one volume to the
disillusionment right and then you come
down and say okay then it matches so
this is the state of maturity this is
where it starts making sense right
so this is where the technologies go now
the reason is important is if you look
at you know few of the things which is
responsible ai ethically many of these
things is going to take some time to
graduate but then the digital ethics and
the age computing and the iot and fiji
and of course you know edge computing
with the advent of yg which is much low
latency is going to be reality for
tomorrow right in the entire space of
age computing to what what we call as an
iot right uh and again lot of data
coming forward a decentralized computing
energy right or the centralized
decentralized computing but here is
where there is mn right
here is where we are really talking of
anything like the eliza or the chat bots
or the computer vision for you to find
defective parts in your water cast iron
what it is right open drags and all of
it so this is where it is so it's time
that you really embrace this technology
because it is coming to the state of
maturity
and then what are the different careers
that one can offer over here and the
multiple careers that we're talking here
now there is enough which is spoken on
the right hand side right which is
anything like keras tensorflow libraries
keras is you know the set of apis
and of course the tensorflow from google
is is aligning to that gives you the
free open source library for you to play
around with it uh there are different
stacks that you can use over here you
can use in a root map to use or you can
use hdfs hbase what artists right but
the point which i'm making over here is
across the
software engineer you could be
statistician you could be anything like
you know data munching wrangling data
engineer
you have different jobs that you have to
play over here there are different roles
to be played right
because there is a data analyst and then
there is a data scientist and there is a
data engineer and you know all of these
in different ways and shapes are
extremely important in this entire cycle
which i said earlier and i will repeat
that we are really talking of the data
engineering part of it the data
preparation part of the data science and
analytic part of it and data
visualization part of it right and all
of these are extremely important because
that forms your entire workflow and in a
way a different view of that
which is very important so i'm going to
start with this if you look at analytics
leader right you could be a data analyst
or you could be a project manager or
information architect
again data is the new natural resource
gold mine we talked about all of that
right
you could be analytic specialist
or you could have a business acumen and
business domain so i'm going to coin in
a term right i don't know who spoke that
so i'll call it as mine may be right
which is technology is only as useful
only as useful as it can put to business
use
lasers were invented many many many
years back i don't know who invented i
forgot about it and laser as you know is
a light amplification of stimulation
right
but then it's only useful when it came
to the precision cutting and you know
multiple things that we really do and
the lasers are not exactly the sci-fi
movies by the way there is no such thing
you can stop the laser after one meter
and use it as sort yet of course you can
use it for cutting but the point which
i'm making is all of these have this
multiple
vein diagrams which you see
and the intersection of the statistics
are the mathematics because when you're
talking of any of the stochastic
gradient descent or the xg boost or you
know the shifting
the averages such as the reem algorithms
all of these basically are the
statistical techniques in a way right
even
what you do into the explainability is
also very statistical techniques right
to the technology and the technology
could be anything that you use right you
could use golang or you could use water
that you know you could use no water
that you're using today or that you're
comfortable today that or it could be
python or it could be r or you know used
spss in ibm
and then the business document very
important right the intersection of
technology and business is important and
that is where is the data science
so let me skip couple of charts over
here i'm just keeping my clock active
over here i want to give some time so
let me just take two more minutes right
uh i'll probably skip this chart as well
here is something which is an
interesting chart
so here we are talking about social
dexterity and the different skills which
are actually playing a role in what is
going to come into the next decade and
what people also say is more important
i'll probably skip this slide because
this is little too glittered let's just
look at this
very simple chart right and i brought
this in and it's very recent as a matter
of fact right it's just about a year
back that this was released
which was the data prediction for 2020
right
so there is a prediction that this will
create something like a million jobs and
this is the kind of a spain that we're
looking at in ai industry now this is a
chart which we tell you where we are
headed
and i'm going to leave it slow on this
shot right
let's look at this very very carefully
now if you look at the extreme left over
here we're looking at three to four
trillion dollar impact which is expected
in the next maybe
just about 10 years or so or whatever it
is right in less than 10 years
which is about 15 of the gdp of north
america
four trillion dollars is humongous right
it could be not could be it is it is
economy of many countries right
including
you know countries like india as well
and the many countries which are
actually way way way below billion
dollar strength so you can look at the
total impact in northern europe 10
percent you can look at china 26 percent
right in asia and then a few other
countries over here so what does it mean
right look at the person now
this means that all the regions of the
global entire global economy to the
extent of 10 trillion dollars
is humongous right and that's a
humongous opportunity in front of us so
if you're doing any data science courses
today data engineering process
uh let's be assured that you know your
few decades later who knows what
technology is going to be a decade later
is quite in safe hands because you have
the biggest job opportunities over here
and then multiple other things which is
talked about over here so i'll probably
skip that i have just last week so i
want to quickly answer
so now let's just talk the last thing
which you promised earlier which is does
it mean it's a banana boom right does it
mean that he's gonna take her the jobs
you know when i was young
uh much younger i graduated about 36
years back
uh there was this you know the
computerization as a word just coined in
because i grew up with mainframes my
first company which i saw at punch cards
and i used punch cards myself and you
know the perforated tapes as well right
but of course you know the world is
different now
so there was this notion that
computerization is going to take the
jobs away but let's let's just look at
it feinstein
uh look at 100 years back right i'm not
going all the way back to the 16th and
17th egyptians and you know the roman
strength i'm just talking 100 years back
my grandfather
your grandfather and probably
everybody's grandfather probably as a
farmer
because farming was only profession
and then came the entire civil
engineering right and people thought
this is the only profession
then came the industrial automation
which is mostly invited by few asian
countries
and we thought that is going to take
away the jobs because there is
industrial automation and csc machines
and all of those robo shops right
and then came the computerization which
is about 30 years back and people
thought that is going to take away the
job right let me put it this way no it
doesn't take away the jobs
it creates different business models it
creates businesses that you would have
never thought about
who would have thought about just five
years back there is something like you
know done so i don't know do you know
about it but in india there is a dancer
which is if i have to travel from point
a to b within the city of bangalore in
india
i really cannot do that because i'm busy
in a job so i called duns and say hey
can you drop this package somewhere
airbnb
we're looking at the jobs which are
possible today and the businesses which
are possible today
with somebody who is operating the
biggest real estate market without
owning a real estate and the biggest
taxi service lego
without owning a taxi right single taxi
those are the different business models
such as so it changes the nature of a
job it creates an opportunity
more so than ever particularly in the
field of airmen i would you know just in
the glass if i were to say right there a
few technologies which i believe and i
could be on wrong with just that
everybody's point of view
which are going to be the game changer
at least for the coming decades so right
one is obviously the cloud and cognitive
right and cognitive is what we will
talking in this station cloud is a
hybrid multi cloud
uh where about eighty percent of the
clients are yet to move to the public
cloud or multi cloud other i would say
right so there's huge appropriate over
there and of course the quantum
computing there's a lot as i said right
10 million times faster computers you
can imagine
you can solve the problems which are
impossible to be solved for maybe
hundreds of years in just about a second
right and when you're talking about
blockchain blockchain an iot
now when we look at all of these
technologies it is going to give you a
completely different set of
opportunities and of course there will
be some threats that you'll have to ward
off as well
but to dispel the myth on this is not
going to take away the job it creates
7.2 million jobs just in the uk alone as
you can see and making this study says
that and by the way what are the reports
i have shown you were from mckinsey or
gartner or a forest or idc right it was
something which was amoled say right the
numbers which just says 10 trillion
dollars is not almost number right it's
just vacancy number
uh so you can see in a number of um job
shift and um
you know the change in the nature of
jobs right and the last thing that gonna
call out is
what does what do we need to do in the
changing nature chaos is one of the
things that i just a little sometime
back which is
when we're looking at the ethical air
responsibilities of the ai in all of
these it's not just about the kind of
care that you need to take in handling
of the data right it's also about
you know the whole empathy in in i just
came from ibm to kendra we have
something called a garage sinking method
where we are really looking at how do
you understand the problem from the end
user's perspective and you know be in
their shoes which is you know we have
you know the empathy map which can be
created right
and the soft skills that we're talking
about which could be anything like you
know
uh the kind of the human care that
you're taking that's why i was telling
that you know the job like a nurse or a
caretaker or the police
or you know your order the country's
security rights soldier
it's very difficult that we'll hand over
to the ai right away at least not
exactly of course we can argue that a
few of these
you know the drones that you need to
automate to the extent to which
in the cases which are extreme
you may want to save the human life so
that i'll not use the words which i
should not use but
um you know beyond that there are
certain skills which are creative skills
social skills
emotional skills empathetic skills right
these are the changing nature of the
jobs where you know anything which
you know
quite often when i go to my doctor which
must be happening to you as a right when
i go to the family doctor it's my trust
in the doctor
it may not matter what medicine the
doctor gives me honestly it's just the
fact that he or she tells me that yes
i'll be cured and it's just about two
days and i have to do abc
it's about the trust which i have it's
about the empathy it's about you know
the emotions right which actually cures
me half of it and the rest will be the
dogs take care of it right so these are
the nature of the skills which are
required in the industry uh so everyone
has to be aware of it so net net in
confusion
i think i want to wind up and um i
wanted to take not more than 45 minutes
i think i'm just at the boundary over
there so let's just open up for the q a
um
in in
you know in in winding up
i would say a couple of things
um
and i'll probably start stop the
slideshow there is no reason for us to
go from structure right i will stop it
over here just talk learning right
so one of the things that we talked
about is
you know how important it is and what is
the important role that it is going to
play aml in the entire ecosystem for
decades to come and certainly for the
very near future right
and what is the social responsibility
that we carry
and what is the high process reality
right i mean doing a course which is
just about famous course does not
necessarily equip you
to compete with the people who
understand the data right because
there's an art and science together
uh so you'll not really train yourself
give us some time
and then of course the last thing that
we talked about is just because there is
an ai and just because there is an ml
and then there's a dl does not mean that
the jobs are taken away
despite the fact that i said yes yeah i
can paint a picture and can write a
novel and many things and it has
invasion our lives
it is also to say that it created and is
creating different opportunities for us
and way to embrace that right and we
need to of course mind those
opportunities as well so let me stop at
that and let me see
uh what are the questions that we have
and you can take a few questions
yeah well i've got the questions queued
up and um
we have a question from neil who asks
what are the future connections between
mechanical design
and ai and machine learning so how can a
mechanical designer engineer
approach the field of ai
well a perfect question as a matter of
fact i would say you know it's um
ai is associating with almost everything
allocation couple of examples over here
right if you're talking of some kind of
machine design itself
or some kind of an industrial automation
industry automation which is also called
computer vision
today can of course in production plant
on the assembly line can have a soft
rays
uh scanning through your cast
to find out internal stress and strength
and analyze it to see
if this part is something which is okay
to be shipped or not right
which otherwise humanly is not possible
because at the outset it may look better
the other thing is if you're looking at
a very simple thing which is the
aerodynamic model of a car if you're
trying to
you know design anything uh which is
let's say a formula one kind of a car
right you can understand that even at a
speed of something like 70 or 80 mph it
can actually start
getting those you know the wind
pressures for it to get generated left
how do you stop that you actually create
the mechanical model through ais for you
to do the different models and
understand that how do you really
stop the drift and you know spoil the
driftwood it's called a spoiler at the
back of the car right and how do you
actually look at how that airflow kind
of you know the the wind patterns are
going to be
um it's it's i would say invaded into
all parts of the industry and certainly
into the mechanical i just gave a couple
of examples of that
but if your question is little different
maybe i'll just stop at that yeah
um
we have
several questions from
current students and they're asking
what kinds of skills should they be
studying
to prepare for a career as a data
scientist or to go into aiml
i think this is a
terrific question right
um so let's let's just step back and
look at it yet again right we just
talked about ai and ml as a tool right
so i would call it as a means to an end
and not an end itself
so quite often you know people confuse
that if i really know something like you
know c or c sharp or go like a python or
whatever the computer language that you
talk about or in anything that you're
talking about is a means to a name it's
not an end itself
so what are you preparing your career
towards as a first person if you are
trying to be architect in the services
industry
if you are trying to actually create a
product and there are multiple products
and multiple startups which are coming
in and today is a time that you know
many of the startups are encouraged as
well
if you are trying to create anything in
the retail industry for instance you may
want to look at market basket analysis
promotion analysis you may look at
customer buying behavior analytic and
there are multiple things right and i
can just give a couple of examples so
there
we quite often analyze what is it which
can get sold together
and if you try to do amazon shopping or
flipkart shopping whatever that you use
you'll see that you will get this which
is you know customers who bought this
also about this
now we are not talking about machine
learning here we're not talking about
deep learning here we are talking of
using deep learning to actually do the
sale
or to arrive at a promotion which is buy
one get to free or buy to get one free
what it is right today it is so
complicated businesses that you can
actually find out this business sense in
making
that if you buy shirts from me i will
give airline discounts right i'll give
some coupons for you to dine at a
restaurant so all of these are extremely
complicated and that is the one that is
where you need to build an expertise in
so the first thing is that what you want
to be right here is down the line if
it's coming quick question coming from a
student right you want to be data
analyst you want to be a data scientist
you want to be a data engineer you want
to actually go to a domain such as a
retail or health care whatever and then
apply this technology
towards that
so i think that's important i'll just
give a retail example right market
basket analysis is an analysis where
somebody tries to buy something and does
not make a decision or the customer
buying behavior analytics i just tell
you funny story which is probably you
are already aware of it there was
walmart is one of the 300 billion dollar
giant right they sell more than 100
billion per year right just a revenue
and just in christmas they make 2
billion so they start to do a study
which is
which is that product which is sold most
often with a diaper baby diaper
now here is the analytic right
surprising that it may sound that turns
out that a beer and diaper go together
don't ask me the reasons why but study
shows that most of you know younger
families ask their husbands to return
from work and pick up the diapers as
once you look at the diaper look at the
next hail look at the beer and pick it
up right but that is the analytics
without analytics you don't have known
about it right that's just one of the
examples
okay
um we do have a
question about
the
definitional
differences um
so
could you give a
just a brief
description of what data science is then
what
ai is and what machine learning is so
that
and then deep learning is as the fourth
one
so that you can kind of
get
of the layers
maybe i'll just go back to
if i can share back again right
i think i should be able to hear it okay
so i was just trying to
oh actually here you are right so any
one of these is basically machine
learning right and anything which is a
deep learning so i actually want wanted
to go back to the chart which is
somewhere over here
so the deep learning i thought i covered
this shot right
so ai is a larger terminology
which is any of the intelligence that
you bring in to perform a certain
business function
which acts like human and hence it is
artificial rather than
you know natural intelligence and
intelligence is kind of cognitive
cognition is what is the neurons you
know all of this terminology is
basically
we have the neurons in our heads right
and we actually have the cognition which
is thinking abilities right and
artificial intelligence as a term which
was pointing as i said right somewhere
in you know 50s is basically a problem
solving where you are trying to mimic
humans in solving a problem right
but then we are not talking of so it
could be a simple rule-based model a
rule-based model is also an artificial
intelligence model if this then this if
not then this right you can have one of
those things that's also ai right
multiple things like fuzzy logic systems
export systems as people called it
earlier these are all ai systems but
what is machine learning is an ability
for a computer ability for a machine
to be able to understand when being
thrown into the waters not literally
waters what i mean by you know thrown
with the problem right so you throw a
data set let's look at unsupervised
learning what am i doing is i cannot
afford to do labeling of data millions
particularly from you know the streaming
of the data right which is real time so
i'm gonna actually throw machine
learning at it and let the machines are
the neurons of the machine right which
could be forward propagation drops back
propagation whatever it is
learn
how to actually infer some sense out of
it and get some conclusions out of it
right so that is where we're talking of
some kind of a machine learning whereas
the deep learning is the one
which is primarily the depth of the
neurons in the forward propagation of
the back propagation that we talk about
cnn for instance is a feed forward
mechanism under multiple cnn algorithms
that we talked about right our rnn which
is recurrent is the back propagation it
has a memory element which is lstm
the hierarchical tempo memory these are
deep learning right the test here is the
depth of the perceptrons depth of the
neurons how deep you can actually go
right it takes time it takes compute
right it's more complex problems and
again it depends on you know what is the
precision what is the recall and f1
you're looking at when you all really
want the model to settle do you have you
know any label data unlabeled data so
that's the kind of difference between
machine learning and deep learning and
yeah right what are the other questions
to it one was
in the
in the broader context of
what else does data science
encompass
so the data science actually will
encompass
according to me three major things as i
said right which is the data engineering
aspect of the data preparation aspect
which is why we talk of
you know handling the data
the imputation of data the enrichment of
a data massaging of a data
the data compression deduplication all
of these data preparation stage and the
data science is an analytic stage data
science is where we're looking at
supervised learning we are talking about
different models which could be recently
naive scan and exe boost what it is
right in trying to understand that model
trying to impose that mathematical model
trying to get the results and validate
the results have continuous learning
well the two two most right you can
train a model and throw it to the
problem
and expect that it actually behaves
properly it may not so it needs to have
that active learning or continuous
learning so that it continuously learns
and kind of you know adjust and tweaks
itself uh very difficult to do but you
know that's that's how the thing should
be right
so when we're really looking at the data
science part of it it kind of comprises
of this data engineering part of it the
analytic part of it and even the
visualization part of it or the
influence part of it
so that entire thing is a data science
it's a science of a data simply put it's
about
inferring something out of a data the
data is i said it earlier right i'll say
it again
the data as a gold mine is only as
useful to you as you make use of it and
it can be put to business use
otherwise the data had always been there
right imagine the weather patterns were
there right millions of years back
we are on this mother earth for five
million years as a human race right did
we use that data we did right
and of course people lost lives people
lost the countries when the oceans got
flooded right so now we are looking at
how somebody can save i stay in india
and just about last week or you know
early part of this week chennai was
inundated with us because of friends
right
now we can actually predict these things
which is that prediction which is what
the data is telling us all the way the
patterns
so now we are trying to make use of the
data so that is the science of the data
right
which is what it really means the data
engineering past part of it data science
part of it which is another part of it
which is the core let's just call it
analytic and of course the data
visualization and influence part of it
and and
the gold mine is an interesting metaphor
because
in mining
um
in the real world mining means taking
tons and tons and tons
of ore
and then
extracting looking for and extracting
the small amount of useful
materials minerals or
other things from that ore so
it's the same kind of thing
it's a great metaphor for a lot of
applications and data where there's so
much data coming in that it's
overwhelming and yet somewhere in that
flow of data is the valuable information
that's important to your
business your operation or what have you
so
um
that's that's a
interesting way of looking at
the purpose of data science
we have
a
question from nicholas i don't mean to
laugh at the question it's just it's a
struck me
machines be intelligent enough in the
future
to
uh the extent of replacing human
expertise in the industry so this is
kind of like the question you asked
about will the machines take our jobs
and do you see
the effect of ai on humanity as a future
positive or negative
uh yeah the indeed indeed
um
um
so the way i look at it and the way we
all have to look at it is technology is
here to change
uh today we are talking of this ai ml
data science maybe you know for years
later it could be a little different
variant of it and as i said earlier like
data science has always been there we
looked at the history of it for ai which
is just about 50 year old a plus right
from all the way from the allen turing
models
um
but just before that i want to quote
something
um i just get recalled of a quote from
sir edward deming and in case you don't
know
edward deming is the one right after the
second world war uh was actually
attributed to
the quality control for japan and japan
emerged like a phoenix from there
so japan as a country attributes the
quality control and
all of the quality techniques to
education edward deming actually said
this
that in god we trust
but all the rest please bring your data
so data is so important right and i
thought i'll just quote that
and i really like this in a world war
examples because alan turing also is the
one who was the one who really broke the
code of this um
you know the the german
machines the enigma machines right so
coming to this right what is the data
science career and you know is it a
threat or banner boom right
you know we have to always look at the
technology disruption coming our way
and this disruption has to be taken in
the positive side for us to look at what
different opportunities does it flow in
front of me
and you would have looked at you know
multiple opportunities there was a
dot-com burst in my life and uh stuart
you must have seen in your life as well
uh in the year 2000 when i really woke
up to the first january 2000 i wasn't
too sure the money is still in the bank
whether my vehicle will crank and run
the road with the traffic signals will
operate
and you know all of those fears were
there and there was a company which was
born called google which used that
opportunity again for data mining and
again for search engine
and today that's in history right
so ai is not a threat ai is a couple of
examples which i gave right
the examples and the best example is the
kovid vaccine that i talked about
whether it is from aesthetic or whether
it is from you know
um modern or whatever it is right the
clinical trials the only way you can
shorten the cycle of 12 years to less
than a year and actually without doing
any mammal trials and without him doing
so much of human trials
introduce that n-mass to the billions of
population is not a joke probably this
is the first time in the history of
humanity that it has happened right
which is only because of ai
so there is no question about it that
it's something that we have to embrace
with both einstein and will have to
always look at the fact that it creates
three opportunities and i give a couple
of examples right airbnb which are the
examples which i gave you right
these examples wouldn't have been these
businesses wouldn't have been possible
in yesteryear saturn
so what are the jobs that is going to
create you just saw that it's about
millions of jobs and trillions of
dollars of economy which is moving
around it
can you imagine 10 trillion dollars by
2030
and that is mckenzie cannot my data 10
trillion
look at the job opportunities look at
the you know the new offerings and
products and services that are going to
create around it it's not just for the
products it's about services
it's about the offerings which is brand
new that will actually come into the
different walks of life
it could be an entertainment it could be
media it could be traveling
transportation it could be all over the
place right
um
and it's interesting when you think
about a future
with ai some people think of uh
you know the like you said pop culture
of
ai machines taking over the world and
and
enslaving humanity but the other
view of ai is that
to the extent that it helps
people be healthier
better fed
a better educated
have more economic opportunity
it creates less and less reasons for
people to be in conflict
so
ai is a
technology that has the promise
of helping to make a more
more peaceful and and
or equitable world
um we did have a specific question
speaking of equity
the supreme court of india
uh
adopted
uh let me see if i've got the question
is it
am i looking here
here it is this framework of india
launched an artificial intelligence
portal
and is it possible to use ai to analyze
court cases how does it apply in the
legal field
uh absolutely absolutely so i'm going to
quickly answer both the things right and
i just want to give the previous one
little later but let me just talk about
it right
so there is something called india ai if
you haven't gone in and those of you who
are from india you can just go to india
ai portal you can see
the prime minister mr narendra modi also
talking about what is the role of ai in
human life under the multiple seminars
and multiple initiatives which are
launched at the central government level
which i talked about
um now of course in anything which is um
uh you know judge is one of the things
from an ethical ai perspective which is
difficult to actually completely hand
over to air right so that is very
unlikely to happen at least in your
forcible future but can this technology
help
any criminal investigation absolutely
yes right
so let me give an example right
when we really look at the
you know the trail of any criminal
activity which is left behind and i have
to be careful in choosing the word i
know probably this could be here
somewhere else as well
so this involves or even if you are
really trying to mount a chase on
something you are looking at multiple
things of that
before the conviction is made of that
individual right he or she
so you're looking at maybe
the anomaly detection in just the
calling pattern cdr analysis call data
records right so what i mean by cdr
analysis is
so if i tell you that there is a data
which is created by my call patterns
obviously there is a data which is
created right everybody creates data
right and i told you there's probably
one say 160
zettabyte of a data right
and 300 extra bite every day
so when i actually call up all
maybe you know call my sister or my wife
called my brother right uh it all looks
normal right now when you look at
millions of the records and find out
there is a pattern which emerges
can you as a human being look at
millions of records absolutely not there
is no way right but i tell you with
cognitive intelligence which is the
cognitive intelligence and we could
actually use that into the machine
learning and actually make that machines
work for us right in order to find a nab
a criminal right that do in real time
because imagine right imagine
that you want a criminal not to board a
plane where on tour incident can happen
right
you want a criminal not to do an
unproduct you know water activity into
any public uh crowded place it needs to
be nabbed well before that almost in
real time very difficult right but if
you're looking at a call just to call
pattern analysis how is there going to
help you know the simple ads for
instance right it could be anything
any of the models that you can use which
can tell you that if i have a sim card
if i'm calling a certain country
only in the midnight of my time only for
two minutes and mostly on voice or ip
does it ring a bin
probably does
right i'm not using the actual gsm or
i'm not using you know wll or anything
any of these technologies
i am using voice or ip
and i am calling on you for two minutes
and i'm hanging up and every day or
every monday so there is a seasonality
and there is you know many of the things
that we talked about in amel right so
can the technology be used to nab a
criminal or that absolutely and this is
just cdr right
there are multiple other things that you
have to do you have to find out what is
the raw material that that person is
buying is there something that a normal
human being normally does not buy
am i actually there are many things
which i cannot actually quote over here
but there is huge and humongous data
analytics which is used
in any of the criminal cases and any of
these activities i know this is being
aired but i actually used to work for an
intelligence agency to an extent and i
can tell you the fact that yes there is
huge data analytics which actually is
humanly impossible the reason the same
reason as i said monipal hospital right
which is the way that any human is going
to look at five million x-rays or five
million mris to be able to conclude that
this young looks cancerous and you are
in stage one you in the sense not even
audience but somebody is in stage one
right
i wanna quickly very quickly flash one
slide because to address the previous
question so i just want to go to this
slide which i think is
kind of talking about what's uh come on
come on come on come on come on where is
that where is that
i thought one slide which was quite neat
yeah this slides pretty neat slide right
i know where i picked it up from what
lies ahead right so this is more to the
previous question
look at what's coming in personalized
health care i just picked up at random
right i gave an example that you know
with all due respect to of course the
medical fraternity today the technology
doesn't allow them to do this on their
phone you know can i actually look at a
day in which
i can go to the doctor and say this is
what has happened to me he can find the
root cause he or shea water can find a
root cause in a jiffy using ai ml
whatever it is right using these devices
and say okay this is a symptom and these
are cause let's just address it at you
know root cause level and for your
genomic sequence and your genomic
pattern and your dna
this is a medicine which has to work for
you in this exact quantity personalized
medicine
isn't that an opportunity absolutely
personalized insurance trust me
if i am doing a treadmill and i'm doing
you know what are the exercises to keep
my all the parameters in control like
blood sugar and chlorostall and what are
you right ggts why should i pay the same
insurance as somebody who is dual my
weight
just because of an age how is the
insurance computed in many countries
today
just based on your age is that the right
way to do it right why do i pay car
insurance as much as anybody else when i
don't even drive the car more than a
kilometer a day right
you shouldn't the car insurance be high
driven right shouldn't it be data tv and
so look at anything you know homo
homomorphic encryption
look at the deep learning that we can do
in data centric systems right anything
in blockchain for instance ring which is
a distributed laser which is a secular
asia which is you know completely
different way in which you can track
your supply chain in which you really
look at you know any interpretability of
the data which has been coming to you
you will have more conviction to take a
vaccine with blockchain then you have it
otherwise you'll have more conviction to
do any financial transaction with
blockchain than otherwise right and all
of this is possible because of the data
which is out over there so we can talk
of multiple examples of environmental
solution digital agriculture there was
you know one i belong to one of the iits
but we're working with my own irt on the
time series data which you get from the
indian remote sensing satellites for you
to look at the soil fertility and for
you to look at the crop rotation
look at the opportunity right this is
exactly what i'm saying
15 10 years back was it even possible
you either did not have the data or if
you had the data you don't have ways to
compute it
or you did not have any kind of a hybrid
multi-cloud real estate that you'll have
to buy capital investor you know
investment that you got to do that you
couldn't do even the iits could not do
that right today it is possible you can
go go on a cloud and buy what are the
capacity that you want for what are the
number of hours that you buy and you can
crunch this data near real time to look
at the fertility of a soil
and then the retention of the water
retention in that soil and then give the
advice about the crop rotation
in the state of punjab this is one of
the iit project that you know we're
involved with was it possible for years
back no isn't that a great business
opportunity to tell the farmers that
this is the crop that you should take
and you will get the maximum yield with
the least amount of fertilizer and make
it organic we can go on right
so i'll just talk about that but yes i
mean that's an opportunity every threat
my friends is an opportunity right it's
a question how do you really look at the
problem right i want to give one last
exam i know i'm just drifting too many
things right but there is this which i
don't know what extent is true
there was a company which was sent by
you know the
the queen's england right sometime to
another country and then say they sent
two agents right one agent went in
surveyed for that product came back and
said absolutely no chance this country
does not use this product at all
other guy went in and came back almost
gleaming to say you know what nobody
uses a product look at the goddamn
opportunity over here we are talking
about footwear
one day you see 200 back 200 years back
rather in a container says there's no
chance nobody uses a footwear the other
guy says this is an opportunity nobody
uses a footwork why not we launch a
product we have to look at a problem as
an opportunity right and there is an
opportunity but i mind that
that's
a great story um
and it's interesting also that we're
looking at a time when
we're still
learning about
machine learning
i mentioned it and
something that's in the news in the
united states is
the company zillow
and zillow makes much of its uh
business model out of estimating
how much your home
property is worth
so you can go on to zillow and type in
your address and it will say
your house is currently worth this much
and it uses things like how much of
other houses in your neighborhood sold
for recently and
what is the size and
configuration of your house and how many
square feet or square meters
is it
so zillow became so confident in their
prediction models of pricing that they
started to buy houses
on the idea that they would know which
houses to buy that would go up in value
that they could then resell quickly
and make a profit
and they've been doing that for several
years and they just announced
within the last couple of weeks that
they will not do it anymore
because they have realized that their
pricing model is good
but it's not so good that it can
absolutely predict the future
with enough certainty
that they wouldn't
they wouldn't um
have an unanticipated decline in house
prices so
they have realized that
there are certain limits to what ai can
do today and maybe in the future
with more experience and with more
understanding they'll be able to build
even better models and return to that
but it's it's an interesting aspect of
artificial in recognizing that
artificial intelligence is not
infallible
and that people have a role to play
in a world that's still
you know enhanced by artificial
intelligence we have a question um
in terms of you know what would somebody
from say an arts background or a
non-technical background
need to do to prepare
to make a pivot into
data science and artificial intelligence
oh terrific question and um you know
allow me to shave back again because
this is exactly what i was talking about
right
um so one of the things which i said is
again you know these are the means to an
end right when you talk about particular
technology for instance
uh i just gave a kind of an analogy of
uh again the computer language that you
use mine
it used to be c in olden days and then
it was cpp and c sharp and now it is go
line which is similar to c or what it is
right rust and tick stack and
different phase right again all of these
are means right so if you look at
multiple carriers over here right
you could be a graphic designer
or you could be a statistician
or you could be visualization expert so
if you're from an art background you
could be a graphic designer right
or you could be you know any of the
information specialists we are really
talking about data science which kind of
lies at the intersection of
the business acumen
the mathematics or statistics and then
the technology right
so
again depending on the domain that
you're talking about
you could be a person who understand a
retail domain you could be person who
understand whatever it is you know
traveling transportation domain
and for that maybe you're an arts
graduate you're a commerce graduate
you're a media trained personal or your
whatever profession that you are in
right
this is one glue which is going to be
certainly useful to you based on which
domain you want to apply it and
and no matter which domain you're
talking about you will have enough an
abundance of the data for you to process
the question only so i give agriculture
right
one of the fields which is the most
ancient fields
in humanity
probably more than 5 million year old
right probably it's about a couple of
billion billion years old right so when
we really talk about agriculture
you can put the technology to
agriculture and just give example of
soil retentivity water attention in a
soil or soil fertility so you could be a
graphic designer you could be an analyst
you could be whatever the profession
you're in right so what i advice to you
is prepare yourself for first of all
what do you want to do
choose your domain right you could be in
commerce dominant exact you know what
what are the what was talking about the
same example
if you are really looking at
i'll give you an example of
what actually is a real problem that i
was trying to solve
let's say you are a businessman and you
are trying to open a new franchise store
of a pizza hut
in the city of patna i'm just making it
up right our city of bangalore just
check that
we where exactly should we have this
should we have it in indiana another
area
or should we have it in
you know i'm just giving bangalore
example
in some very orthodox area where people
don't eat anything at all and don't eat
out so you know there is an analysis
which needs to be done for you to find
out which is the best place where you'll
make the best business i'll give an
example of something that you know
will actually working with
where should be
the replenishing of the atms is an
analytical problem that we are solving
in the real time perhaps imagine that
the two atms one at the airport and one
at railway station and i'm giving an
example of maybe in india right
you can imagine that at railway station
the number of transactions are more
but the actual currency is less people
will draw 100 rupee 200 rupee 500 rupee
very unlikely 10 000 rupees whereas you
go to the airport number of transaction
are less
but they are high in the value
so the currency nodes that you want to
replenish in both the atms of the same
make at two places would be different
and where do you place an atm is also an
art not just a science right
because of the vandalism i shouldn't
talk in air about vandalism but
you really have to look at before you
place your atm
is it susceptible to vandalism and if so
how much of currency you wanna dispense
over there right you're gonna put huge
currency
you know in the areas where you're not
too sure of right yeah so
this is art and science together so no
matter which profession you're in
apply data apply the data science to
your field
don't jump to the data scientist as a
profession to solve any problem that
data science can solve because that
domain may not be yours
choose your domain and apply the
technology to that
you reminded me of a particular question
um
a real world example of
something that
when you when you talk about using ai to
determine where to locate a business
it's an interesting phenomenon
here in the united states
that
when you find a gasoline or petrol
station
you find
two or three or four together at the
same point
and
you can think of that as a really old
uh piece of uh
learning that people had that if if this
is a good place for him to sell gasoline
then it must be a good place for me to
sell gasoline
and
today with ai you can be more
intelligent about it by saying well wait
a minute
why should i be right where someone else
is competing with me
are there other places that i can go
where people
would need to have this
that they don't have it currently and so
i can be the first one or the only one
there
and not have that competition so that's
a
that's an interesting way that that uh
you know we've gone from old ways of
making decisions to new ways um
we we have a couple of questions that
came in from our streaming uh service um
one asks about
oh yes i i i i just started taking one
minutes to it right i actually should
have mentioned earlier so just just give
me a minute on that so there's another
one last thing that i wanna mentions to
it is
you know for all the participants for
still on
um though it looks like a very lucrative
field and something that you know i
should really go for irrespective of
what you're doing art science commerce
medical hospitality whatever background
that you're in right
uh as happens in any field
um one can be too enthusiastic about it
and jump in maybe you know the simplest
thing you do is you know some you see an
indexing search like a google search and
then find out how okay i found a course
and i'm gonna do this and you know in
one overnight i'm gonna actually turn
these tables and you know boom i'm gonna
get a great job and great career and you
know a great happy ending story right it
doesn't happen that way what you really
need is a guided tour
right let me stress on the guided tour
right
if i have only half an hour and when i'm
going to you know paris and i'm looking
at water you know i'm going to england
and looking at you know one of these
monuments like water the salisbury park
for instance and i have only half an
hour i'll just go roam around waste my
half an hour without understanding
anything i'll come back right i need a
guided tour to make the best use of my
time of day right
so the guided tour that you can take is
the one that you can get from somebody
like simply learn
so that is the tour where there is an
industry collaboration like us in drill
and earlier ibm and many of these you
know the sessions that we do together
many of the course curricula that we
drive together many of the industry
participation that we have together
so this is one of the fora that you
should really use which is
you know let the experts solve your
problem
let you not venture out all by yourself
because there is a good possibility that
you will be inundated and you will be
lost
and once you really look back and then
you say gee i could have done it
differently right
so while you say today is an opportunity
it's much better that you take the
guided tour from you know somebody like
simply learn who will tell you what
exactly needs to be done rather than
getting lost into and you know it's too
easy to get lost in the weeds as a
quality
and then it's very difficult to get out
of it right so be smart and choose the
right course so sorry i just want to
mention that that used to work i
appreciate appreciate that it's it's
important and
you know i put just into the chat just
now a link to one of our programs which
is the
ai and machine learning
master's program with
purdue university and ibm
and
that
kind of meets the the criterion you said
of
not just
taking a course but taking a program
that has hands-on experience with
projects
with
labs that let you practice what you're
learning and
expert things like ask me anything's
from ibm experts and
that's really a way
to get shepherded through
and
get to an end point where you really are
prepared and can demonstrate the skills
that an employer might be looking for so
i appreciate you mentioning that um
last couple of questions before we
finish because we're at our
hour and a half but
uh
ravine on linkedin asks about data
privacy
uh for customers
and how ai affects that
yeah i think again a very good question
right and particularly very relevant
today praveen because
you know today we're looking at uh today
in the sense in the last few years we
look at the gdpr norms right the general
data protection
uh which is quite prominent in europe
for instance uh it's certainly coming
into the north america and then into
asia and then other countries as well
right
so while i was talking of this data
residency norms and data handling now
residency analysis for instance
uh today unless you are a canadian
citizen for certain businesses in canada
you cannot even handle the canadian data
and if unless you are a citizen of a
certain country
in a certain business you can't handle
the data beyond 128 bit of encryption
right
and all of these are statutory norms
which are applied for a certain reason
and those reasons needs to be respected
as well
uh so when you really look at the data
protection and data handling it's very
important in the design aspect itself
while you're looking at designing a
system and even deploying a system
so one is obviously designing a system
and then of course you know executing
that clone and you know creating that
and then deploying this right
validating it testing it and deploying
it and sometimes there is a continuous
learning and continuous deployment as
well
so the aspect of data handling is a very
important aspect of design
while you're creating any of these data
science systems particularly in the data
handling part of it which is data
engineering as i said earlier right and
today with this decentralized computing
with hybrid multi-cloud
uh now we are really looking at this as
a global village right yesterday years
were more data centric
where you had more of an on-premise data
centers
uh today it is hybrid multi-cloud
meaning they buy i mean why i have it
multi-cloud it's not even cloud i would
call it as serverless computing right
where you can use some amazon lambda
functions for instance you can use
certain services on the fly
and these services can do some
computation for you can do what are the
you know
uh what are the computation facts that
um services different consumer offerings
that you want to consume and makes it
far easier and you don't even care
sometimes where the parts is right where
are these cloud services being offered
from but when the statutory norms demand
you to be cognizant about it
of course it needs to be part of your
design element itself
so depending on the problem that you're
really trying to solve and bigger
depending on the industry that you're
really working on every industry has you
know different norms so i mentioned
about hipaa for instance right which is
quite prominent in many countries for
the
healthcare information data privacy and
healthcare is an information which is
certainly very private to you
even gdpr makes the privacy in arms
right
whether you're a data provider or
whether you're just acting on it data
being provided to you
you need to handle it with care for it
to be because you are the owner of a
data
when you're actually processing it
and that needs to be a design point in
the system that you're designing
okay so it's very important
i wanted to ask the one last question
before we close
from
francisco on linkedin who asks
do you think industrial automation is
going to ultimately be replaced by
ed computing with
ai no no no no i think i think you said
age computing right um edge computing
yeah right
so let me just define the age computing
right
there is a lot that people are talking
about age computing today
uh so age computing is primarily
uh let me give an example in the yester
years we have this centralized computing
centralized data center and no matter
where your businesses are all the data
is brought back into that kind of a
centralized place for processing
and then all the decisions are made
there into you know the back end itself
so let me give you example of walmart
for instance right yeah they're probably
about 450 walmarts across the 50 states
of united states
and all of these walmarts if they have
to send the data to washington dc first
of all the data itself could be private
data because it could be amal bought
something in walmart is a very private
data what i bought is my business nobody
else should know about it right it could
be anything that i buy or any quantity
that apparently so that data with all
the security and in real time possibly
is coming back to your data center at
the back data center is processing it
and then giving what is a confusion that
conclusion could be a promotion on
christmas it could be on thanksgiving it
could be whatever it is right and the
promotion can be our plenty as i said
right i won't get to free or reduce the
fast better price by 20 red dot express
sell midnight madness cell water right
all of these different terms right
now when we really look at age computing
we are looking at having this
decentralization
where the domain will shift and every
state can take its own decision
and the reason could be
that every state may even observe
different festivals if i give an example
of india
the festivals which are celebrated like
oh no for instance in south india are
not celebrated like by sakhi not india
so why would a particular store
equivalent of walmart in india should
have a same promotion at the same time
across the country it doesn't make sense
right so now there is a decentralized
computing
another thing to really look at and that
is age computing right another thing to
really look at is
simple case which is you are trying to
enter your premises of your bank for
instance which is you know 150 branches
across the country are you using your
biometric
to probably record your presence
imagine your extremely sensitive data
like biometry
is traveling all across the globe to
some pod in singapore where there is
public cloud where it is getting
processed right out of india
and you are talking of you know some
state we are trying to do fingerprinting
right
now you can look at what is an age
computing why is that needed right so it
is autonomous entity by itself which can
take at least some part of the decisions
at an age
or decentralized so that is an age right
and extend the age
to the industrial automation or the iot
now right which is where i give an
example of 5g the low latency messaging
of 5g is far different than 4g
the 2g 3g 4g was a natural succession
but now we are really talking of 5g
which is a completely different
technological way which could be
different discussion which is a low
latency ring so 5g or advent of ige
enables the age computing to be truly
making iot possible iot could be
anything it could be an autonomous car
it could be a you know a deep sea drill
machine where in case you don't know you
spend 20 million dollars
in trying to do an oil well
and when you do an oil well the
extraction of oil per minute and per
hour is so important that if you extract
less your yield is less if you extract
more the oil will rise up
20 million dollars busted
so what is the best quantity that you're
gonna extract per day per minute per
hour is an ai technique right which is
an iot now because there is an
autonomous decision that the drill
machine and that extraction plant has to
take on the fly based on the data which
is being presented there there is no
reason for that entire data to be
transmitted back to the back end at all
right of course there is a reason for
you to duplicate the data
compress the data and the sent to the
backend for some historical time says
analysis you know time series archival
that's a little different story now
coming to the industrial automation
right yes there is an industrial
automation which has been there for the
last i don't know how many years right
there are car plants not just in japan
but even in india today
where the amount of the manual workforce
is far lesser and the cnc machines are
taken over right but that is rightfully
so
which is not to say that ai is going to
replace the humans over there right it
is more to say that it has brought in
more precision it has taken more of a
risky jobs away from you
and industry jobs are risky quite often
which has you know taken those jobs away
from you and you are making it you know
far better
but is there going to be a day that
there is going to be no human at all
into any one of these businesses i don't
see that in near forcible future
so you'll always remain to be part of
that plant
and the the business that you're going
to do or the job that you're going to do
in that plant is going to be quite
different than doing the manual quality
control or manually trying to fit in
maybe a screw or not over there right
it's going to be our manual painting is
going to be little different and that's
the point that i've been stressing right
this is a business opportunity and this
is a change in the way we are really
looking at the business and let me just
take last example i know you're going to
notice time right you know what this is
again my point of view and
everybody's entitled to the point of
view as i said right
my point of view is the conventional
business says that you can sell a
product and make a business i would
argue
that tomorrow you're gonna sell a
service on a product on that product and
make more business
and i tend to believe that the companies
like beamers and the teslas and all of
it
will very soon make more business on the
services that they give with all of the
ai which is there in their cars right
i mean today seated in the car i can get
an app telling me that the actual psi in
my right tire is less
how is it actually happening there is an
iot sensor over there which is sending
some data to some iot hub or a gateway
or a router which is going to some
backend or some edge processing over
there and it is connecting to the app
and sending the data that i'm all in
your tesla on that right the actual psi
is little less right you might want to
inflate the tire now that is a service
which i'll pay for
right it's not the manufacturing of that
car in the industrial automation right
it's a service which will tell me that
in the conventional car my brake fluid
is low and actually running the risk of
my brake efficiency being low
so the services that are going to be
offered and the products will probably
make more money in near future and that
is the business opportunity that we
should exploit rather than thinking
about to make that particular car or to
make that particular product is there
automation which is going to take my job
away maybe it does but then it creates a
different opportunity for you
so look at that right
actually such a service did not exist
earlier this service on your mobile
phone with an android app or ios app or
whatever 10 years back you couldn't
imagine that seated in the car
somebody's gonna tell you you know what
actually you're running a little low on
to this or whatever it is right and it
is going to actually pose a risk for you
some airbag probably has stopped
functioning for you it could save my
life
how much will i pay for that service
yeah interesting interesting convergence
between it service management and
maintenance management of mechanical
systems isn't it
i'm going to
conclude the webinar
um
first i want to thank
you i'm all for being here and be
extremely generous with your time and
your expertise
so i want to share with people um
how to get in touch with you through
linkedin
and there is his linkedin
url i'm going to put that into the chat
as well so
but
before we finish
i'd like to do a real quick um pull of
the audience
about
their plans
and
let me get to the pulling here
and again
take about
45 seconds to
consider this what are the things that
you're interested in learning
uh as it relates to
the things we've talked about today
and when do you see yourself
getting involved in that starting with
that so
and while you're doing that i will see
if i can drop the
linkedin link into the chat
yep there it is
so in
just a couple seconds
here's the result of the poll
and as one might expect
those first three choices data science
ai and machine learning
are of the greatest interests of the
audience
data engineering
cloud computing devops project
management all
have a few people that are interested so
you can contact us and it's good to see
about half of you want to start doing
that right away
you can contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
to ask about courses
you can also visit our
website i'm also going to drop in again
the link to
the postgraduate program
course page and what that will do is
tell you about our ai and machine
learning
program
in conjunction with purdue university
and ibm
it'll also give you access to our
website and you can explore other
courses there
and with that um
just invite everybody to
our next webinar which is in two days
if you are interested in
digital marketing or if you know folks
who are
please let us know we'd love to see you
at that webinar as well but it's an
entirely different topic
and
keep
tabs on us through our social media
simply learn at facebook and twitter
simply learn on
linkedin
and thank you again i'm all for being
here thank you and everybody for being
with us thanks everyone
yes
thanks
yes
and that concludes our webinar for today
uh one last announcement we will be
sending out an email tomorrow with a
link to the program recording for this
uh session
so
you'll have the ability to re-watch
and
catch up on anything that you might have
missed
all right thank you all and take care
you